digamos que tenemos un rayo un rayo que
inicia
y pasa por un punto b y lo podemos ver
qué línea tan recta
así está mejor ok lo podemos llamar rayo
ave entonces inicia nada tiene un
vértice nada ahora digamos también
tenemos otro rayo un rayo que pasa por c
entonces trazo
el rayo que pasa por ser a este rayo lo
llamo rayo hace ahora lo interesante en
esto es lo siguiente lo interesante
acerca de estos dos rayos es que tienen
exactamente el mismo vértice
y cuando tenemos dos rayos con el mismo
vértice tenemos un ángulo y entonces
quizás tú ya estás familiarizado con la
palabra ángulo el concepto creo viene
del latín esquina y tiene sentido pues
en el punto aparece una esquina pero la
definición geométrica la cual es más
común es cuando dos rayos comparten un
mismo vértice y ese vértice común es
llamado el vértice del ángulo entonces a
es un vértice y no solo es el vértice
del rayo ave y del rayo base es el
vértice del ángulo
ahora bien de lo siguiente que te quiero
platicar es cómo nombrar a un ángulo y
quizás en este caso te sientas tentado a
nombrarlo ángulo
pero ese nombre no quedará tan claro
entonces la manera en que especificamos
un ángulo dice es ángulo y este es el
símbolo de ángulo y vemos que tiene un
parecido enorme con el ángulo que
tenemos aquí pero esta cosita puntiaguda
que parece el símbolo de menor o igual
no lo es
este es plano por abajo entonces les
presento al símbolo de ángulo y decimos
ángulo base o decimos
ángulo se ve en cualquier caso estás
especificando esta esquina en esta
abertura en la y lo importante es darte
cuenta que tenemos el vértice en medio
de las dos letras
entonces tal vez digas por qué
molestarme por escribir las tres letras
porque no simplemente le puedo llamar
ángulo a ella
pues por la siguiente razón que te
muestra en el diagrama y aunque la
definición geométrica de ángulo aunque
ésta comprenda a dos rayos que tienen un
mismo vértice en la práctica tuve los
ángulos compuestos por muchos segmentos
de líneas y puedes imaginar que estos
segmentos los puedes tratar
infinitamente en la misma dirección y
entonces se convierten en rayos de esta
manera son consistentes con la
definición
ahora bien entonces tengo este segmento
y nombró al punto d al punto e entonces
tengo el segmento d ahora digamos tengo
otro segmento que lo corta al cual
nombró los extremos el punto f y el
punto g tal que la intersección de estos
dos segmentos está en el punto así
entonces cómo puedo yo especificar este
ángulo lo podemos simplemente llamar h
no no no podemos hacer eso porque porque
si decimos que ese es el ángulo h
entonces yo puedo decir que también
este otro es el ángulo h y crearíamos
confusión entonces deja los dibujos de
esta otra manera puede ser este ángulo o
puede ser este otro ángulo oeste de acá
o también puede ser este de aquí
entonces la manera la manera para de
verdad especificar de qué ángulo estamos
hablando es dar tres letras por lo tanto
si de verdad queremos hablar sobre este
ángulo lo llamamos ángulo hg entonces
pongo aquí ángulo y hg o también lo
podemos llamar ángulo g h y ahora si
queremos especificar este otro ángulo el
compuesto por imagina este radio y este
otro radio que siguen este infinito y
pasan por esos dos puntos el punto d y
el punto g entonces podemos llamar este
ángulo ángulo de hg ángulo de hg
ángulo g hd y así es este asunto
entonces por ejemplo este ángulo puede
ser
efe h hf este puede ser efe hd o de hf y
haciendo esto queda muy claro de qué
ángulo estamos hablando y ahora que
tenemos una idea general de lo que es un
ángulo y de cómo lo denotamos con
símbolos otra curiosidad tuya puede ser
parece que no todos los ángulos se ven
igual parece que otros se abren más
otros menos y así y en efecto ese es el
caso entonces por ejemplo tomemos los
ángulos digamos tengo un ángulo que se
ve así
y lo nombro voy a repetir letras tiene
su vértice en a y tiene aquí el punto b
y el punto ce y estos segmentos de línea
yo los puedo extender infinitamente
convirtiéndolos en rayos o los puedo
dejar así entonces tengo el ángulo de
hace y también tengo este otro ángulo
el ángulo con un punto x vértice en jr y
un punto z también nos puede extender a
rayos estos segmentos de línea los puedo
dejar así entonces tengo el ángulo x y z
ahora cuando los observamos cuando vemos
detalladamente a los dos ángulos tal
parece que éste está más abierto más
abierto
y que el otro estaba más cerrado al
menos el relativo al otro ángulo esto
está más cerrado luego quizás cuando
medimos ángulos debemos basarnos para
medir en qué tan cerrado o abierto está
y en efecto ese es el caso entonces sin
decirte cómo medir un ángulo puedes
decir que la medida del ángulo x z es
mayor que la del ángulo b ac y cualquier
convención que utilicemos para medir
ángulos será esencialmente la medida de
qué tan abierto o cerrado está el ángulo
en el próximo vídeo te voy a mostrar
cómo medir ángulos hasta pronto